the united nations has called for action
to avert what it calls a sand crisis
demand for sand has surged to 50 billion
tons per year amid population growth and
urbanization now sand has become a
highly important natural resource but
its use is largely uncovered
it's all around us on the ground in the
air and more and more in glass concrete
and other construction materials
sand is the world's most exploited
natural resource after water
and over the last two decades global
sand consumption has been surging
alongside construction to 50 billion
tons a year
that's around
kilograms per person a day
the un says we are now consuming sand
faster than it can be replaced by
geological processes
exploding demand means more sand will be
needed
meanwhile the effects of unsustainable
sand extraction are already being felt
in parts of the world
one major example according to the u.n
is southeast asia's longest river the
mekong its delta is sinking due to sand
extraction and that has led to
selenization of previously fertile land
the u.n warns that sand extraction is
also destroying beaches and ecosystems
something that will hurt fishing and
tourism more regulation may be the
answer
sanderman is anticipated to increase
both to fit with population growth
migration from rural to urban areas and
catching up development and that will
only increase demand for this strategic
resource and that requires formalizing
its value the way we think about it
regulating a natural resource that is
everywhere the u.n also wants to see a
ban on sand extraction on beaches
the question now is whether governments
business and most of us will heed this
warning
all right for more on the story i
welcome to the studio my colleague
chiponda timberloo
chiponda there's so much sand around in
fact there's gazillion tons of it in the
sahara and other deserts how did we end
up in a sand crisis
exactly chris that is a question that a
lot of people would be asking obviously
but the thing is that not all sand is
the same and doesn't have the same
qualities and the stand in the desert
which there is a lot of one must say is
actually not so great for construction
and commercial use it tends to be
smoother so that means it can just stick
together and you have to add lots and
lots of water to get it to
be used in construction and even then
it's not like quite good as the sand you
would get at the bottom of a river or
the sea so that's one reason and of
course the other reason is that most of
us thought there's a lot of sand so
we've been using it like water oil like
air like it's never going to run out and
this is something of course that the un
is warning uh the fact that we don't
know exactly how much
of the industry how it works the
fragmentation
more information is needed in order to
be able to come up with solutions to fix
this looming sand crisis if you like the
un has recommended more regulations
started starting with banning the use of
beach sand what else can be done
well what they really are asking for is
for local stakeholders to be speaking
with government and private industry to
figure out solutions because of course
one of the major issues is that the
saturn industry like i mentioned is
quite fragmented a lot of people are
informal workers which means they need
to be part of the solution because of
course if you ban for instance
extraction of sand from beaches or river
beds in some parts of the world what it
means is that those people don't have
jobs they don't have a source of income
so they need to be incentivized to stop
extracting the sand and be given
other jobs and other opportunities that
would allow them to leave that work for
something potentially even more
lucrative and this is what the un has
been calling for and apart from these
incentives how feasible are these
solutions and recommendations oh i would
say i fear um based on what i've read
and what we've seen that they aren't
very feasible because of course a good
example is the fact that within the last
decade in a three-year period china had
used as much sand has as had been used
in the 20th century for construction
by the us and that was a good example so
it's really hard to regulate we need
everyone on board and that is part of
the problem getting everyone on board
ews chipotle thank you